et j'ajoute que la Bourse de Moscou
plongée lundi matin de 10% à son plus
bas depuis le début de l'offensive
contre l'Ukraine on va plus loin avec
vous aux leg cobzef bonjour et merci de
répondre à FRANCE 24 vous êtes historien
et géographe professeur de géopolitique
à l'American University of Paris d'abord
comment est-ce que vous analysez cette
concession du Kremlin ce matin qui admet
donc des erreurs au sujet de la
mobilisation partielle
oh il y a d'abord peut-être un peu de
panique mais finalement la narration
qu'il nous sert oui
pardonnez-nous il y a quelques bavures
quelques erreurs ce n'est pas
reconnaître au moment la situation qui
est en train de se dérouler c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une partie de la population
qui commence à résister à la
mobilisation et on a le sentiment c'est
un peu de l'improvisation permanente là
depuis cette annonce de Poutine
ah mais oui la plus grande la plus
grande improvisation de Poutine ça a été
déjà cette guerre c'est de ne pas avoir
compris que d'une part nous ne sommes
plus en 1941 et va pas y avoir un
une mobilisation spontanée de la
population contre un ennemi externe
parce que les gens Russie ne sont pas
complètement idiots ils voient bien que
oui il y a un danger il y a un danger
américain certes mais ce n'est pas la
grande invasion des nazis
il restait jusque là c'est passif mais
ils savent ils savent très bien que que
c'est c'est très exagéré donc en
revanche mobilisation peut-être pas
générale mais peut-être c'est le début
c'est le premier pas vers une
mobilisation générale ça montre primo
que que ça va très mal sur le terrain
puisque quand même on a déjà envoyé 150
soldats et on ne sait pas très bien où
ils en sont et quels sont les vrais
pertes donc c'est très inquiétant et
deuxièmement si on mobilise si une
mobilisation partielle maintenant
pourquoi pas une mobilisation générale
par la suite mais d'autre part là où
également Poutine a complètement
improvisé c'est ne pas avoir prévu que
les Ukrainiens eux réagiront comme des
citoyens soviétiques en 1941 quand les
les nazis ont attaqué et troisièmement
on s'imaginant en jouant comme un enfant
à la guerre
à la deuxième guerre mondiale la grande
guerre patriotique comme ils disent
là-bas s'imaginant qu'on va faire un
remake de cela parce qu'il a vu trop de
films produits par par ses propres par
ses propres deniers et bien il
s'imaginait que voilà que le peuple
russe allait se soulever comme le peuple
soviétique en 41 42 sans réaliser que
les Russes d'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
du tout les les Soviétiques d'autrefois
ceux de simples consommateurs qui certes
n'ont pas beaucoup protesté faut pas
trop exagérer ces manifestations qui a
eu au début qui n'ont protesté oui mais
pas massivement au point au point de
faire trembler le régime c'est des
consommateurs avant tout donc il y a un
regard et donc excusez-moi donc il y a
un changement d'attitude des Russes
parce que là ils estiment que la guerre
risque de les toucher personnellement
ah bah oui c'est ça c'est que maintenant
l'heure n'est plus à regarder des
sopopéra et aller faire du shopping
là maintenant la guerre les frappe dans
leur chair on vient leur porter des
petits papiers alors à leur domicile en
leur disant voilà donc 48 heures dans 24
heures vous devez vous présenter là là
ça fait mal du coup cette mobilisation
partielle elle devait concerner 300 000
personnes on voit bien qu'il y a des
ratés des incompréhensions est-ce que
l'on sait aujourd'hui qui sera
mobilisable et combien
alors on dit 300 000 c'est égouts qu'il
a le ministre de la défense qu'il l'a
dit d'ailleurs alors c'est très
intéressant de voir la manière gênée
dont il était interviewé il y a quelques
jours il avait vraiment il parlait avec
la queue entre les jambes et d'autres
personnes qu'il faut dire à propos de
qui est qui sont mobilisables là ce
n'est pas maintenant le problème et
c'est le problème qui dure depuis le
début de la guerre depuis depuis février
c'est d'ailleurs que ce sont la chair à
canon ce sont souvent des minorités ce
sont des bouriades des des Tchetchen des
les petites ethnies qu'il y a dans les
républiques autonomes ou ailleurs en
Russie ce qui est en fait un remake de
ce qui se passait au Vietnam n'est-ce
pas le les noirs qui étaient recrutés
pour partir au Vietnam c'est-à-dire ceux
qui étaient littéralement envoyé sur le
front était infiniment
excessivement sur représenté par rapport
par rapport aux blancs ou à d'autres
là c'est un c'est un c'est un problème
réel qui ça c'est que ça pourrait être
sain le un facteur de déstabilisation
d'ailleurs du régime ou au moins
localement parce que effectivement ce
sont les ce sont les minorités ethniques
qui sont recrutés avant les autres ou
alors là on recourt également à des à
des droits communs en leur propre en
leur proposant un peu comme dans les le
film Les 12 salopards une qu'on leur
efface leur casier judiciaire si ils
sont volontaires pour aller sur le front
merci beaucoup les effets pour votre
commentaire sur France 24 à propos donc
de cette mobilisation de citoyens russes